lying during a deposition can have very
serious legal consequences including
perjury charges perjury is a criminal
offense it can result in imprisonment it
can result in fines but of course
remember
proving perjury is very difficult this
is why I mean listen you and I know
people lie all the time under oath in
court they say things that aren't true
and many of them know that the things
they're saying are untrue but why don't
you often see perjury charges because in
order to get a perjury charge to stick
you have to demonstrate that the person
knew what they were saying was untrue
rather than it was the result of a
mistake in recollection or a lack of
recollection or whatever the case may be
very very difficult the other issue with
lying during a deposition is that you
can be held in contempt
this is all so unlikely to happen to
Trump but it is again more of Trump's
dishonesty more of Trump's inability to
just shut his mouth